To answer this question we want to write code that
looks very similar to the code from before. We want to
create a box plot to compare the distribution of the number
of friendships initiated for our male and female users. So let's
just remind ourselves what variables we have in our data frame.
So for friend requests, I think I'll use friendships_initiated that sounds
right. To make my box plot I'll pass x the variable
gender, since that's my categorical variable. And then I'll pass y,
friendships_initiated. Now I need to subset my data frame just like
from before. And then I'll need to tell qplot that I
want to box plot. So I'll set the geom. Looking at
this plot, we see that most users make less than 500 friend
requests. So let's set our y limb setting zero as our
minimum and 500 as our max. So I'll add the cored_cartesian layer
and set my limits. It's really close, but it looks like
females have slightly more friend requests. Since the median black line is
slightly higher for females than this median black line
for males. Now, this might be too close to call.
So, I say we should zoom in again. This time,
we'll change the upper limit to 150. Yeah, it looks
like females initiate slightly more friendships on average. Let's also
check this with a numerical summary. I can use the
by command and split friendships_initiated by gender and then, find
their summary. So, I'll take my friendships_initiated, split it by
gender and then run a summary. And here's our output. And
we can see that the median for females is 49 whereas
the median for males is 44. Now, you might be wondering,
why should we even create this box spot to begin with if
we can answer our question with a numerical summary. Well, it's
helpful to understand the distribution of the data. So in the case
of the box plot, we can see the middle 50% of
values for each segment of our categorical variable. Our box plots also
let us get a sense of alliers. So in one
way, they're much more rich with information than just this table.